one of the conversations that we've been
having on the show probably for a year
and a half now I'd say is a conversation
about what are the longer-term
consequences of this first Donald Trump
term the ways in which politics has
changed the ways in which what is
acceptable language and and discourse
has course and we've had a lot of those
conversations some relate to alliances
with foreign countries some relate to
well here's a list of executive orders
that could quickly be undone here's a
list of executive orders that would be
more work for the next president to undo
but one of the most important sort of
changes their effects of the Donald
Trump presidency is on the presidency
itself and what I mean by that is that
the effect of the effectively toed the
that I don't is that that were twice the
effect of what has been essentially
total immunity from consequences for
Donald Trump's actions are going to be
felt not just if Donald Trump gets a
second term but during the remaining I
guess eleven months of this first term
Donald Trump believes now that he can
get away with anything and he's right to
believe that because he possibly can and
this is why I do not believe we will
have a peaceful transition of power in
January of 2021 if Donald Trump loses in
November look at all of the things that
Donald Trump has gotten away with with
essentially no consequences and I
alluded to this earlier in the show and
said I wanted to talk about it you look
at the Russia stuff okay whatever your
view is on it his behavior was not
perfect when it comes to Russia but
never were there really going to be
consequences for Donald Trump from the
Moller investigation we suspect that
Donald Trump is experiencing some degree
of cognitive decline or confusion we
don't know exactly what because we can't
get a actual workup medically to figure
out what's going on but there was no way
that the 25th amendment is going to be
used to remove Donald Trump the
emolument stuff the ways in which Donald
Trump has had four foreign diplomats and
others come and stay at his hotel in DC
to funnel money directly into his family
business and then the bigger ways in
which Donald Trump has funneled money
into his
pockets when he travels to his own clubs
and resorts when his campaign funnels
donor money right back into his pockets
by using donor money to rent out event
spaces and hire catering from Donald
Trump's own restaurants and hotels and
venues we've talked about it all before
Trump's participation in Yemen of via
Saudi Arabia as a proxy and that
completely immoral humanitarian crisis
there have been no consequences for
anything with impeachment of course now
being at the most recent of being the
most recent example with his acquittal
on both articles this week getting away
with everything
no witnesses in the impeachment trial a
prejudged conclusion in coordination
with Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Trump's personal lawyer is
running all over the world doing
so-called drug deals that's what Trump's
own former national security adviser
john bolton called them arranging
corruption he'd now is joking
increasingly about being president
longer than the Constitution would allow
and in fact I know that these are all
these are like 98 percent jokes two
percent serious when he does it posted
to Twitter a video yesterday which we're
now going to show our video audience
where there are signs flying by saying
Trump 2024 Trump 2028 etc I get it
big joke triggering the libs all that
stuff but if Donald Trump loses in
November of 2020
I don't expect a peaceful transition I
expect claims if it's a close election
I expect claims that it was rigged or
that the counting was wrong and that he
didn't really lose if it's a big margin
if we do the thing I'm saying we have to
do which is turnout in such overwhelming
numbers that we outdo the voter
suppression and the meddling and the
interference and all of the stuff if
it's a big margin Trump will say it's
too big of a margin it was obviously
rigged fake and phony it was fraud
we need a recount or we need an invest
in an independent investigation bring in
some kind of special investigator
prosecute or whatever now I've said
before Trump won't ultimately get away
with it if Donald from
losses in November I do believe that it
is not going to be the Justice
Department that saves him I believe
ultimately Donald Trump is going to have
to leave but it's not going to be
peaceful I still find it odd by the way
that there are still so many people that
think Trump will completely peacefully
say but you know what we lost we had a
good run at it we I will peacefully
transition to the next president of the
United States particularly if it's quote
crazy Bernie or sleepy Joe or whoever it
is that it will be Trump is beyond
unhinged Trump has already questioned
the credibility of an election he won
remember Trump won in 2016 electoral he
lost the popular vote there is every
indication that that is the reality that
that is not some kind of farce or fake
phony numbers and Trump questions it if
Trump spends three years continuing to
question an election he won imagine what
will happen if the guy actually loses so
when I say as I've been telling you guys
for a while we need to win so big in
November that they can't cheat or that
they can't use voter suppression to win
or whatever what I'm essentially saying
is that we need a margin that is big
enough that it won't let Trump deny the
democratic process and of course again
if it is a huge win he'll still try to
deny it by saying it's too big of a
margin it's not believable that I would
lose by that much clearly it was rigged
I'm worried people aren't grasping the
magnitude of this we are you know as I
say before sometimes I say it in a
positive sense a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step at the
same time the long journey to
authoritarianism also begins with a
single step and sometimes it moves so
slowly that you can't even notice we are
well down the authoritarian road at this
point in time when you compare where we
were before Donald Trump was inaugurated
to where we are today attacks on media
and suppression of journalists and
journalism that the White House doesn't
like it's just common it barely is a
blip on the radar at the
point-in-time trump regularly gleeful
and praising the authoritarian types
that many of us feel are the most
anti-american thing while criticizing
our Western historic democratic allies
it barely even makes headlines anymore
and in fact many trumpets agree they
like the Assad Hooton kim jong you know
whoever Duterte types and are glad and
agree with trump when it comes to his
criticisms of Emmanuel macron or Angela
Merkel or whoever by the way Angela
Merkel no bleeding heart liberal to
begin with so Trump is a symptom of many
underlying problems and not the cause
but he is an exacerbating symptom he is
a symptom that is making the problem
significantly worse he wants people to
believe that voter fraud is the reason
why he didn't win the popular vote in
2016 even though yes he won the
electoral college
imagine if he loses the election okay he
will do whatever he can to Kontest it he
will try to get it tied up in court if
he will succeed is anyone's guess I
maintain that if he loses he will
ultimately relinquish power but I don't
believe it's going to be peaceful let me
know what you think about this I want to
encourage everybody in my audience to go
subscribe to a YouTube channel we're
partnering with it's called up flip they
release new videos every week in every
video you meet a different entrepreneur
and get an in-depth look at how their
business works and how they became
successful it's great if you like shows
like Shark Tank if you own your own
business or you're thinking of starting
one the up flip YouTube channel really
does offer a wealth of knowledge and
inspiration as an entrepreneur myself
and a business owner I've really been
enjoying hearing all of the different
stories of the people that they
interview but it's really fascinating
content even if you don't own your own
business to go check out the up flip
youtube channel they're friends of the
David Pakman show I'd love it if you
would support them by subscribing to
their channel you can find the up flip
YouTube channel by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip you're watching
this on youtube i've put the
right underneath this video